[Music]
curiosity is the most powerful thing you
own imagination is a force that can
actually manifest the reality I came out
of that movie and I thought that it's
unbelievable how much you want to go
there and it's interesting how they have
created that feeling that pandora is
actually a place and a beautiful place
where you think you would like to be the
game should deliver on that promise it
should be the ultimate experience where
you actually go to Pandora and where you
can live an alternative life on the moon
we are working side by side with
Lightstorm to create a game based on the
world of Avatar with the power of
massive snowdrop game engine and the
team's passion and obsessive focus on
detail we know they're the right group
to bring the beauty and danger of
Pandora to life
it's a mesmerizing world that you want
to visit and see with your own eyes
to now be able to recreate that in a
computer game is a fantastic humbling
experience the excitement is enormous
and it's it fits very well with many of
the things we are interested in ecology
sustainability fighting for what you
believe in a lot of interesting values
that really resonate well with the team
our mission is always to make the best
games in the world in this case I think
we have a unique opportunity to do
something that is very very rare
every player gets to choose how they
want to experience this incredible
universe we're about to embark on an
amazing adventure the insane attention
to detail is one of the key things that
made Pandora feel so real when we're
done everybody will get to experience
the beautiful world of Pandora